the Joe Rogan experience was messed up
yeah and that happens in sports this
this is what I think makes fighting so
great so great max has an opportunity
that no one else in the world in sports
can have and then you know then look at
Canelo triple G it's it in in combat
sports this is what we deal with yeah
Canelo that's the biggest fight of the
year biggest fight ever wants to see the
rematch of the year and then tainted
meat do you buy the tainted meat
absolutely not sir
I've had many tacos in Mexico and I'm
not small yeah but you're not getting
tested for trace amounts of clenbuterol
you don't know maybe I have to go and
snitch come my house just for the [ __ ]
of it just me I'm still in the testing
protocol mmm
no I may be I don't know but I'd see
some sort of change but even triple G's
camp goes last fight he was on it what
else is new now why did Tripp what do
you think they said that he'd I don't
know I'm sure listen I'm sure gennady's
been in there with what over 500 people
now 400 people and you just said in his
experience he can tell who's on peds and
who's not and he thought Camilla was do
you buy that I do I do because that a
fighter as a fighter this guy's I fought
who I assumed were okay but what about
wouldn't Lee a guy like Woodley he has
tremendous genetic he's always been like
that right always been like that but so
is Canelo no hmm you look at he's he's
young pretty swell
now he's getting older though so it
could be that too he's just as you get
older you put on more sighs well the big
one was Manny Manny was the one that
everybody was always accusing and Manny
is the first I mean Manny went up eight
weight classes and kept his knockout
booze fighting as a little boy and then
just was like crazy I mean and kept the
knockout power true and most people
thought that Manny was on PE d correct
and then they thought that man he got
off peds when he fought Juan Manuel
Marquez and he got starched but yep
there's two there's a two-sided story
there he got off peds and also found
Jesus Christ so he stopped going to
strip clubs
he stopped hanging out with girls but he
stopped having fun and then right got
serious about Jesus and gotten like the
[ __ ] out yeah Jenny saw Jesus and that
[ __ ] geezers like listen if you want to
be a savage you got to live like a
savage she's like I'm not even if I
this man just like do your thing yeah
take them steroids like listen I made
steroids okay that's cameras your god
that wheatgrass ain't gonna help you say
that's good for you but you need good
but you need this too depends on what
you are I mean if you want to be 147
pounds artist I me but marques is no
stranger to the night skin supplements
no no no no no no no no no no well
here's they had the same strength and
conditioning coach when Manny found
Jesus his old strength and conditioning
coach went over to the doctor wet mat
Juan Manuel Marquez he's always on the
dark state on the dark side that dude
was always in the dark yeah Morty what
was he doing now Hiep Alex Alex Alex
Ariza Ariza yes good call brother yeah
he knows a [ __ ] man he knows his [ __ ]
and I don't know whether or not he's got
anybody on peds either just blaming him
knows his [ __ ] as a strength and
conditioning coach that guy's very very
yeah out of worked wasn't if I was
fighting I saw the stuff that he was
doing with why my mom Marquez I was like
this guy's he's super legit and he
brings those guys up to like modern
levels or preference not the old-school
[ __ ] yeah it's some of the old-school
[ __ ] - to this day I think chopping wood
that's all legit man sledge hammers on
tires that's he was good at it I agree I
think it's good add-in I think deadlifts
all that stuff but I think you mix that
with the new wave of Technology and I
got some well like what I was saying
about Nick curse on and that mark
Marinovich method it's all its plyos man
everything's like jump box jumps and
movement yeah left right left right left
right
you know curse on sets I'm very
interesting to me when I said like what
do you think fighters are missing most
like strength condition wants it foot
strength that makes sense
totally makes sense you know who's been
on that ball since God since I've known
him is Loren Landau who I worked with in
Denver and now he just got the gig as
the number had condition coach of the
Denver Broncos
[Applause]